hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen fifa paar der erste part kam
ja ziemlich gut an bei euch also da war
eine menge kommentare eine menge
positive bewertungen
da hab ich mir gedacht dass ich jetzt
einfach mal noch einen auf nämlich muss
kusmin controller an machen weil ich
habe das kabel von meinem controller bei
meinem freund vergessen und der war zu
blöd wenn es halt nicht mit dem stück
was also heute ist freitag das heißt ich
muss das komplette wochenende mit einer
ladung hier spielen und die es gerade
schon fast im arsch und übrigens was ich
euch mal eben zeigen könnte nach dem
letzten video haben mich übelst viele
leute gemeldet und ihr wisst ihr dass
mein name kontrast und ich möchte
einfach dass ihr das last weil ich nehme
keinen an als wenn ihr euer name bei ist
dann ihr werdet nicht angenommen das tut
mir sehr leid aber das sind echt eine
menge leute die mich dann geändert haben
obwohl ich mein land jetzt so groß
erwähnt habe naja jedenfalls haben mir
viele leute in die kommentare
geschrieben hey das ja von broadcastern
opec auf links macht und so
also ich mach ja nicht nur pack openlink
sondern ich spiele ja auch und habe ich
mir gedacht dass ich mir mal eine neue
mannschaft mache und zwar eine englische
die habe ich allerdings schon aufgebaut
weil sie ein kurzes mannschaft aus
wählen weil ich einfach übels bock auf
11 fifa hatte so mannschaft raus war
selbst schon zweite und ich würde sagen
ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz meine
englische die heißt komm united meine
deutsche heißt fc konnten und dass es
die englischen menge spieler davon habe
ich gezogen sowie raphael wolf habe ich
gezogen die drei habe ich gezogen ich
mir wirklich nicht alle gekauft sondern
ich ziehe auch schon mal eine menge und
den wollte ich noch im sturm packen weil
der weg der taste nicht ganz gut rhein
chemie habe ich 790 ganz einfach weil
ich zurzeit noch keinen manager hat und
ein paar leute auf die formation nicht
so ganz drauf haben also hier der der
zbm ist eigentlich sein
also da müsste eigentlich hier dingen
sind anders sohn von manchester united
und naja sich für zahlen das ist damit
erstmal eine runde spielen weil auch
leute wollten das im online spielern und
die sache ist ja die ihr kennt ja alle
meinen pc hat man wir sind jetzt in
wieder acht wir sind immer noch in einer
saison 1 auch wenn man ein team spielen
naja ok ich würde sagen wir gehen davon
wenn die online sie sagen ich kann nicht
sagen wie gut ich bin also eigentlich
wurde ich sagen dass ich schon
einigermaßen okay spielen kann also ich
würd
viele von euch schlagen denke habe ich
wieder gegen viele verlieren weil vor
allem jetzt in ultimate team jetzt
gerade ist es für mich schwer
ganz einfach weil ich noch nie zuvor
der sonne sein trikot wechseln softgun
cap ich hab noch nie zuvor mit diesem
team hier gerade gespielt mit einem
englischen team das das erste mal dass
ich mit meinem englischen teamspieler
und zweite sache
ich habe die alligator game camp jakarta
dts die ist super und so nur mein pc ist
einfach so schlecht der hat zwar 12 gb
ram aber der kommt trotzdem nicht klar
dass ich gleichzeitig aufnehmen und
gleichzeitig zocken weil das bild musste
zweimal angezeigt werden das heißt es
ruckelt bei mir ein bisschen als es
ruckelt nicht sondern ich merke dass die
bewegungen wenn ich jetzt sagen sticken
kleines stück bewege oder so dass der
dann ein bisschen später erst losläuft
sag ich mal
also das merke ich schon eindeutig oder
auch wenn ich jetzt mal felix gedrückt
hat das dann später kommt das heißt ich
hoffe einfach dass das funktioniert
das ist jetzt nicht allzu flüssig läuft
aber ich würd mal sagen wie wir
versuchen einfach damit zu leben
und ja also die die reaktionszeiten sind
halt schlecht deswegen muss ich mich da
halt so ein bisschen anpassen
deswegen kann ich auch andere
kommentatoren verstehen die das damals
dass ihnen die capture card spielst du
sag ich mal
nein da wollte ich nicht in europa nicht
weit nach oben
verdammt locker noch hinterher schreibt
in liga eins standards sind schon krass
nur mein kumpel meinte jetzt auch
letztens zu mir ja liga eins sind die
viel leichter als liga zwei wie heißt
der typ eigentlich mit dem stadtfest
oder ist frei nein
nach dieser konnte markus heißt der na
ja eventuell welche das weiter so machen
dass die paar leute von euch einfach mal
hätte man gegen euch spiele damit ich
auch so gegen sein vater der von euch
spiele
das soll jetzt nicht heißen soja rettet
mich alle sondern menschen dann sage ich
das schon wenn ihr mich also sollte der
pasta oder zieht in die mitte und
schießt aber passiert mit auf bekommt
nicht an endlich ruhig pace aber ich hab
den engländern bisher wirklich noch
tempo beachtet dass sie schnell sind
weil es ist in abwehr vor allem sehr
wichtig dass engländer der den ende
kriegt
das hätte ich nicht gedacht es ist
allgemein bei denen die sind alle gut
schnell
es ist einfach solche marke die am handy
haben lübeck die haben
valencia die haben nani die haben diese
alle ziemlich schnell
jetzt habe ich ein tor kassiert oder c a
deutlich
eventuell werde ich alt ansprechen nach
kommentieren also ob man alles geht
schief aufnahmen perfekt zusätzlichen
mittel abnehmen jetzt und zack und das
fasten dass ich eventuell bald mal
spielen nach kommentiere und sage ich
mal dann die besten szenen rausschneiden
und dann das nachher kommt ihre sowie
die man das halt in der sportschau macht
sag ich mal jetzt durch sie durch die
durch alter den krieg setting krise
schneller pass keller passt muss ich
sagen super ballannahme zieht dann mit
nein jetzt kriegst du ja sehr schön und
besteht natürlich keiner
warum läuft er denn von hinten kein
verteidiger mit dem training
naja schade eigentlich kann ich mich
besser spielen mal richtig aufregen aber
ich versuche dass man das nicht so ist
einwurf übrigens viele leute haben ja
auch gefragt also ich nehme da wirklich
was ist das für ein einwurf bitte dass
das wird mich aufregen wenn ich deswegen
jetzt ein tor kassieren wälder sondern
fritz den einwurf nicht so gemacht hat
wie ich das wollte
viele leute habe ich gefragt was denn
eigentlich deine meinung zu fifa 13
und ich muss sagen jedes fifa gefällt
mir ich hab bisher jedes liefern ab 2006
mehr gekauft
wer politik du kannst schon längst hoch
spielen und vertändelt das einfach nur
seine entscheidung
alles frei alles frei alles reicht hallo
wie geil ist das denn bitte
nein verdammt okay die 413 für mich
finde ich richtig geil ist natürlich
jetzt keine große veränderung im kiefer
und dass das 10 m tiefe
business sag ich mal ist jetzt nicht
dazu gekommen eine tolle wiederum super
wie er der übrigens nimmt so im
zurücklaufen keine große veränderung in
sachen fifa jetzt aber vor allem da ich
dieses mal erst richtig mit ihm
angefangen habe würde ich sagen dass ich
dieses mal das spiel schon richtig
gesucht hat und das spiel sich für mich
jetzt schon gelohnt hat in der rein
gegangen dann wäre ich aber ausgerastet
er hat zwar mehr chancen zur zeit
allerdings ist seine effizienz einfach
mal so im keller wo das war richtig so
jetzt kommt konnte herr der ist
natürlich jetzt nicht schnell hier keine
ahnung wie heißt ich habe jetzt sagen
halt noch nicht so drauf - englischen
namen passt sehr schöner paar sehr
schöner pass und jetzt sieht durch und
das war kein abseits
und jetzt zum glück schneller und der
schwarz mit dass das kind schwarz ab so
klasse flanke 20
klasse gemacht super ausgekontert oxlade
chamberlain von manchester united hier
mit dem zwei zu null
sehr schön gegen die laufrichtung
geköpft ist immer super klasse und 20 40
dass man insgesamt sehr defensiv können
wir das ein bisschen hier verteidigen
markus können natürlich uns glücklich
schätzen dass wir bisher auf los los los
los dass wir noch kein tor rein bekommen
haben von dem markus weil er natürlich
schon als ich denke einfach dass er im
akustisch meine tinte noch sirup oder so
hinter seinem namen stehen also glaubt
nicht dass die eltern im sirup genannt
haben dann würden sie ihn aber sehr
hassen scheiße abwehrfehler war was
mache ich denn jetzt hier
er hatte natürlich mehr chancen aber
muss sagen wenn er die nicht nutzt das
selbst schuld beim gegenspieler ist der
kunde sieht ihn einfach weg
da gebe ich ihnen noch mal der verrät
welcher cook das sage ich der verreckt
in dem moment ich sage nein wenn er
passt durchkommen wäre es auch andersrum
ländern rappelt sich wieder auf ist kein
mann hingegen der verteidigung sehr gut
verhalten ländern geht es besser jan ist
super mann hinten drin kann ja nur
empfehlen auch klasse gemacht schöner
doppelpass klasse klasse danke danke
danke wenn ich so schöner kopfball tor
wird es ihnen nicht so der allerbeste
der wenig bälle fest zwei kopfballtore
zwei chancen zwei tore der passt
vielleicht eben den freien lauf was sag
ich und der versucht es zu tricksen aber
nicht mit mir vielleicht auch mit mir
okay vielleicht auch mit mir nach dem
tor von ich okay coleman torwart fällt
hin
klasse also ich hab hier gerade echt
eine menge glück im spiel
und er da unten ist frei klasse pass
class weitergespielt super
herausgespielt super herausgespielt also
ich bitte sie das nie auch nicht dieses
super herausgespielt sondern dann schon
auf die spieler zur klasse gemacht
lassen dass er dann überhaupt noch dran
kommt er zeigt er wirklich das interesse
diesen trick ja ich fahre ich schon mein
leben lang dieser trick funktioniert
freund von mir macht diesen trick immer
gegen ich fange immer wie geht der und
ich habe bock in die nachzugucken
genutzt nein
ich frag mich immer wieder traktiert
danke und ich habe einfach nie gelernt
und er ist einfach so sinnvoll ist so
ein typischer anfängerfehler vertreten
damit hätte keiner gerechnet moment
übrigens werde ich wahrscheinlich die
tage einen fifa intro haben bzw
bin ich gerade in kontakt mit einem
design studio das war ein sehr schöner
pass aber mein tiefer spielt mit und das
war sehr blöd man werten ihn weil als
keeper nach vorne ab nie war es das
haben wir damals schon der d jugend
gelernt
egal damit glück gehabt das dating
angenommen hat als sonst hätten wir die
regatta also sand designerteam damit dws
hat die machen mir wahrscheinlich bald
thumbnails kanal design intro für fifa
und halt noch ein paar sachen also das
ist auf jeden fall ganz cool vor allem
welche fallen zu haben
und das werde ich dann eben unser bleibt
dann für mich die frage ob ich am anfang
dann irgendwie immer den gleichen klub
machen soll
irgendwann so geile tore oder ob ich
dann in die szene aus dem spiel nehmen
soll
oder was jetzt meine frage an euch wäre
ob er mir dass er mich irgendwie danke
das ist immer so blöd tricksen hier das
dort so lange bis man das weg machen
kann ob ihr mir eventuell links senden
könnte tor oder so was ihr davon haltet
wenn ihr geld ab dass ihr mir die
priener senden könnte dazu will ich dann
aber nochmal extra die mühe machen und
das dann quasi ich die anfangs vor das
intro pack in ein alter da steht er da
am weg man nicht glaubst nicht
das war wieder so schön gespielt der
schickt jetzt unten eine leute mitte und
da kommt ich gretchen sind auch so
übertrieben schiefer gewonnen
die würden nie im normalen spiel so
stattfinden
er setzt nochmal den körper einer der
hier kommen giftig sind drauf hat der
körper dann läuft hier nichts ja mal den
hammer den damaligen den hammer kommt da
nicht durch klasse gemacht sehr schön
smalling super super leistung hier weil
ich mal aus da man zurück nein aber doch
nicht mist wir schwimmen leute wir
schwimmen aber da wenn die
zwei-tore-führung haben durch das noch
ein bisschen dauern ich wollte schon
mein keeper ausfallen
er geht jetzt in die mitte oder hamann
nein nein nein
klasse beim schnarchen die dafür nötige
trickster endlich macht man tricks der
mann gegenspieler vorbei zu kommen er
macht so einfach nur schön aussehen und
zack wir kontern und schießen gleich
sofort wieder das 3 0 mit seinem tollen
sweater
da das hier staub von der schulter
vision und dann mein tier so einfach
supercool zu machen dadurch dass sie die
ganzen tricks vorführt von einer b
dollar doch machen muss erwartet jetzt
werde ich jetzt werden wir den mal so
ein bisschen vorführen so ich das mal
eben hier auf ausgeglichen so ich hab
das jetzt mal auf hohem druck gestellt
dass wir den jetzt einfach mal noch so
ein paar klatschen geben gleich ein paar
dinge in rain senken hier scheiß auf
tricksen wir machen einfach tore
natürlich jetzt in ultimate team erstmal
das wichtigste das man gewinnt weil das
sind alles durchschaubaren tricks vista
ich kann euch sagen der zieht in der
mitte so da haben anwalt schüler
es ist einfach so wenn man eine zeit
hier spielt dann weiß man echt alle
griffe wie seht ihr ich nehme immer den
ball weg man muss halt mal sachen machen
mit dem man jetzt nicht gerechnet hätten
das war ist natürlich unsinn ich muss
einfach ich sag mal ignorieren oder wie
man das nennt man muss peripheres sehen
ausüben
quasi schon vorher sehen wo er hin
spielt das liegt jetzt natürlich bei mir
auch daran dass mein team noch nicht
eingespielt ist sage ich mal
also das jetzt überhaupt noch nichts
funktioniert hier fast kevin phillips 30
aber es ist jetzt keine führung wo man
sagt ja der dominiert den gegner total
also ich muss mich dass man mit meinem
team einspielen
ich muss sagen das was sie bisher macht
mir schon mal sehr stolz drauf klasse
pass richter sogar noch nein hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass der dackel geht haben
wir gleich sofort wieder zurück hier
kommt nach unten oder nach oben
nein das kann in der grafik gut hambach
hambach klasse super gemacht
ok läuft ein fachkonzept die wissen
nicht dass dieser oxlade chamberlain
schnell ist klar klingt jetzt natürlich
nicht zu der allerbeste geschickt wieder
oben
ja das ist lemper dabei das nicht
schnell der zieht es wahrscheinlich
mitte und schießt der und lampard hat
echten geilen schuss ist muss ich zu
sagen na ja super gemacht nein nehmen
doch vernünftig an
da habe ich mir so einen stürmer nach
vorne gekauft für 4k und nimmt er den
ball nicht richtig an aber das auch so
typisch weil fifa 13
visser die machen irgendwelche iniesta
den ball an und iniesta kann den ball
nicht annehmen sag ich mal auf vier
meter entfernung in flachen pass oben
kriechen jetzt schön
ich hätte gern einen linksfuß storage
server ist auch gläubig groß naja ich
versuche das mal was ich ein bisschen
trainiert habe und ob merkel das der
also ein bisschen schon dahin läuft
danke auf den kopf fallen ist natürlich
super dass man daraus klopp ist aber
stimmt ist dass morning der schnell ist
der computer her und er hat sich gleich
100 prozentig in der mitte das kann ich
sagen okay aber nicht
damit jetzt nicht gerechnet und deswegen
kassieren wir hier das 2 1
ich bekomme nachricht falls es gehört
hat diverse äußerst unprofessionell gut
das heißt jetzt dass wir erst mal das
ganze team verteidigen müssen
ich meine wir sind in der 70 minute wenn
wir 50 wären dann würde ich sagen ja
komm lass uns noch 1 nachlegen
aber dann spielt das jetzt einfach mal
hintenrum machen diese ein bisschen auf
ballbesitz das also ballbesitz sind
diese schnell taktiken die könnte bei
ps3 oder auch bei xbox controller spielt
ab der 26
diese komischen tasten und dann diese
tasten wenn ihr die nach unten oder nach
oben drückt dann kommen all dieser
auswahlmöglichkeiten das sind die wände
nach unten drückt deutlich danach rechts
und habe ich bei besitzt wenn er nach
oben drückt dann könnt ihr dann sowas
auswählen wie team racing oder sowas
wenn der gegner den ball hat dann team
pressing dass ihr halt dann versucht in
den ball zu kommen oder so das was ich
jetzt mache es einfach nur mehr als klug
und zwar versuche ich den ball so lange
es geht in den eigenen reihen zu halten
und sage ich mal in den beiden zu geben
aber das kann natürlich auch nicht ganz
durchhalten wenn ich jetzt in den beiden
herren spielen würde wie sonst machen
würde sagt mal dann wäre es natürlich
langweilig zum zuschauen
so nahmen jedoch hin fax und dergleichen
offene schussposition
nein genau jetzt verkauft facto man er
ich hätte euch vorher sagen können ich
habe es vorher gesagt das kann nicht
wahr sein
nach dem 2 0 noch ein bisschen anders
gehen und davon jetzt eher noch das 1 1
m brett 8 liegen die tiefe lagen 3 0
vorne ach so ja okay gut ist ich dachte
wir legen nur 2 0 vorne
der innere sorry das hat jetzt die ganze
zeit gedacht dass wir im dritten
eingeschenkt haben
okay dann werden wir das jetzt noch ein
bisschen gemütlich zu ende spielen zack
zack noch einer was dann los mit die bei
bis zu 90 minuten schön spielen hier die
zeit runter so wie man das macht und
damit das spiel von zwar nicht sehr
schön aber fürs erste spiel ging da
schon mal so 3 2 gewonnen mit con united
gegen top lagen als sein team ihn
wahrscheinlich norwegen nach wieso war
kein schönes spiel aber games gewonnen
das war das wichtigste und übrigens hab
ich diesen sfc münzen booster sei sich
zwar mit münzen mehr pro spiel
30 abzuwägen kultur ja das passt schon
ich habe übrigens ab wochen modifikation
das total bescheuert ich habe nie ein
spiel abgebrochen aber trotzdem jetzt
hier so bescheuerte popen motivatoren
dingsbums weil einfach manchmal bleibt
die play sie bei mir stehen und dann
einfach nichts mehr
also ich weiß nicht was machen sondern
möchte play sie aus sondern dann gehe
ich da wieder ran machte wieder an einer
stelle abbrechen multiplikator blablabla
und ja also das ist halt jetzt nicht so
dass alle geilste na ja ich würde sagen
dass war es dann erstmal ja hier mit
fifa ja gesagt dass ich längere platz
machen soll aber nur wenn ich pack sie
also wenn ich im big pack optimal und so
bei ultimate team da möchte ich gerne
ein spiel in einem video packen das
heißt es sind jetzt wieder 19 minuten
vergangen
dort hält er sieht dort nächste spiel in
der nächsten folge von fifa ultimate
team und ja wenn wir dich sagen jemand
wenn es euch gefallen hat wirklich über
einen daumen hoch freuen schreibt 1
kommentar was ich noch verbessern kann
und dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal
tschüss